[Music]
drawing was done by Andrew Harvick
that's how you start off with tapestry
somebody does some concept drawings they
might do three concept drawings and then
they're shown to the person who's
commissioned me the artwork in this case
it was Arctic college in Rankin Inlet
this tapestry is going to be for there a
trade center and it's a trade center so
it's the first time it's a trade center
in Nunavut they wanted to show the
different trades and shearing men and
women involved in the trade they also
wanted to show a juxtaposition of the
traditional culture plus what's
happening today this particular drawing
is referred to as a maquette sort of
like in sculpture a maquette would be
three-dimensional here it's
two-dimensional and then this then has
to be made the same size as the finished
tapestry so therefore then you get this
image and this image is referred to as a
cartoon so all you know what you know is
a cartoon doesn't apply and from what
you normally you know refer to a cartoon
I guess and you'll see numbers it looks
like a paint by number but in fact the
numbers are referring to the different
colors that will be used and each color
that is used is actually woven so that
they can see how it's going to look like
here some of these faces been woven to
see kind of what sort of what colors to
use for their face so everything is
tested so it's very time-consuming
project and to to have so many figures
in a in a tapestry the gain is makes it
much more complex it more difficult to
weave like you have wide open spaces and
it's a piece of cake
doing solid areas of color are easier
than than doing lines lines are more
more fiddly and they're quite a few
lines visible here
[Music]
you